i want to show you something you see
that bankrupt over there i can get in
and out in three minutes
and do what
robert
happy new year
here's the thing no one's born bad like
anything it takes practice whoa take a
look at that for me please need your
help here he says don't scream empty
your drawer
what saw the commotion there's a robbery
across the street
what
every city has its king and in this case
that guy was tommy k i may only have an
eighth grade education but i got a
doctor's thesis in the street i want
some capital for an out-of-town job and
i hear that you are the guy that i'm
supposed to talk to i'm in to partners
in rye
[Music]
thank you mrs claus
wife family nope but i'm available um
so is there anything i should know about
you
do you have any goals
fun facts
well i can't tell you all my secrets
rescue a family
whose place is this ours what
still nothing on them huh not a thing
nothing is a ghost
[Music]
i'll take this one
where'd he go
kill him with success bury him with a
smile what do you think he's trying to
hide i gotta do just one more one last
one
yes i i think i just witnessed a bank
robbery
how many more of those do you think you
can do just like that
this goes down an hour we start a loop
i'd like to make a credit card maybe
oh god save the queen anyone seen this
guy
how would you like to pay for that
cash
you